and
you i heard you saying that are you
handling your own you know and if you
don't want to talk about it that's fine
but you're in the midst of a case right
now with grand master
not grandmaster with uh the record
company grand master recorders happens
to be our restaurant who let their
security handcuff me
on a sidewalk and call the police on me
and lie about what actions well they
were saying that you slapped
the security guard right is that what
the is that what the that is what they
claimed and i'm still awaiting the
footage of me doing that but i stopped
touching people in high school i've
learned i got more to lose than probably
anyone else because
in high school you were 16 and pregnant
so it's no more touching oh it was
definitely like 15 14
so you did not slap this person i do not
touch people
all right so and then there was i saw
that this is for everybody's consumption
they have a video of you being arrested
yeah and actually my friend had a video
too because she didn't know what to do
um
and so she was recording it you know
they could have picked me up and got me
out of there but i understand like with
a guy on top of me and handcuffing me to
himself it was probably a really rough
predicament for my friends to be in
um and it just felt so
i was overwhelmed and i was dealing with
so much ptsd and trauma at that time
like i freaked out but i did post it on
my socials it's on tmz yeah i did post
it on my socials before that because i
was in another altercation like this
where i was set up
and
said i touched people or whatever and i
didn't so i did post on there and i just
was like i really don't know why people
keep acting like this so are you going
to law school are you attending right
now i am i do have uh are you going i
feel like i shouldn't mention the
university and those things because that
also impacted like
my stay at other universities and i've
always had to stop going in person it's
online yeah so i have to like usually be
online and disagree there's always like
politics with going to school you don't
want to mention the school no but i i
will definitely celebrate when i get my
diploma and show that at the end as
always
does
[Laughter]
why are you always targeted like why
does this always happen to you that's
like that sounds so narcissistic of me
to you an answer that's like why is it
about me
no you've had a lot of attacks no but
why do you feel like you you're getting
attacked more than the average person
more than the average baby like why do
you think like 100 more than the average
person yeah right but what i'm saying is
you were just going into a restaurant
right i was trying to wait for my friend
who was calling the police because we
were attacked upstairs
so i was trying to be the adult and wait
outside
and i have no idea why people came after
me standing there
again i just think like life
is whatever it needs to be and i have to
just overcome it
[Music]